OK.
My name is Sara Seager I'm a professor at MIT I am an astrophysicist I work on planets orbiting stars other than other
than the sun we call them exoplanets. Of Stars Yeah so for every star in the sky is the sun.
And there are literally billions of suns or stars in our galaxy.
So like the Suns was the sun is more or less the center of our universe
but our sun is just one of billions of stars hundreds of billions of stars orbiting all bound together in a galaxy we
call the Milky Way. Yeah so many stars. And now we actually think that we think that every star has a planetary system.
So if there's hundreds of billions of stars there could be trillions of planets in our galaxy alone.
And actually there are hundreds of billions of galaxies out there. So. That's one followed by lots of zeros. So.
Well it took decades if not centuries or thousands of years you know for us to figure out what's out there.
But actually now astronomers have found planets thousands of them everywhere we look every star that our technology can
find a planet around we do find a planet. Almost every star.
And so we just are piecing it all together about the range of planets and what's out there. We also see.
Star forming discs we see that when stars are discs. We also see when stars are born. They're born with a gas.
They're born. We also see when stars are born. They have. Discovery on them.
That's kind of full of junk leftover material and we see that around almost all stars
and out of that that junk that dust
and gas that's left over planets are going to form like forms like the like our planetary system formed.
Yes that's right. So how do I know myself. Right.
As you do you know that's kind of one of those complicated things in science because we can't repeat every experiment
ever done. Like for example my building at work you'll see it. You're going to love my office.
And if it's a clear day even if we're not filming up there.
I'm going to take you up to the roof because we can see the entire city skyline of Boston we can see over to the ocean
of we're lucky if it's a clear day
and we climb up this little crossness ladder that leads to a little crossness we can see over to the White Mountains in
New Hampshire. Now I'm guessing you wouldn't want to jump off that building.
Because you believe in the laws of gravity. So some things are accessible to us we believe in gravity.
And we believe in some laws of physics but we believe in all the laws of physics but some of the marks esle to us.
So it's kind of a complicated thing to get into right away
but in science we believe on these building blocks starting with things that we experience
and some things get more complicated and more abstract.
And
when it comes to exoplanets in some cases the measurement of detection of that planet is incontrovertibly we really can't
describe it to anything else but a planet.
In other cases we see like an indirect measurement of a planet and in that case.
Sometimes it's a bit of a leap of faith to believe it's a planet.
And in some even more extreme cases a planet detection will later be retracted because it looked like a planet was
there. But it turned out to be something else.
It's like noise like if you give you an algae that will make sense to you if you take a picture and it's very grainy.
and blurry you think you see something like a U.F.O. And you know you you. You're not sure.
It kind of looks like something you can recognize you're not a hundred percent sure.
Later you go back and take better images and you see what you thought was there was just a it was just noise.
It was just nothing an artifact. So we sometimes see that as well.
I have many different positions in this field the one I started out in is studying planet atmospheres like on our own
Earth we have air that we breathe. All these other planets also have their version of air.
It might be hydrogen or helium or it might be carbon dioxide or something else
but it's to study these atmospheres of planets far away.
And to try to understand what those atmospheres are made of that's my main.
And that's one of the main things that I started out doing. There's lots of people working on this. Now when I started.
There were very few almost nobody was working on this but now it's amazing. Actually if I could.
Yes it's just remarkable.
Now that the things that I like there are the field was so new when I started that
when people were finding planets other people accused the people finding planets of stamp collecting you're just
collecting these things were going to do with them. It's hard enough to find them.
And many of the findings people didn't believe her.
So they're wondering why was I wanted to study their atmospheres which is even harder to do. So it's amazing.
Now that today. It's twenty years later.
Not only do we have dozens and dozens of planet atmospheres measured but such a standard Now you can come to MIT
and go to a talk next Tuesday a visiting professor will be talking about exoplanet atmospheres
and how complex they are it's now bread and butter mainstream astronomy.
So there's lots of people working on it right now. Well right.
Yes really great question WAS NEXT that Tim such a hard question. But actually again we build on many decades of work.
So for a long time.
Astronomers have used spectroscopy we break up the white light of the sun or star into different colors
and we look for lines that are missing little pieces of let's say the rainbow the spectrum that are gone
and from that we infer the presence of atoms and molecules.
So if you want to know the truth people before us did all the hard work
when they did all the hard work even looking at the sun
and stars we can see many different atoms in the photo sphere of of the sun and stars
and you know it took people a long time to believe that stars were made mostly of hydrogen and helium.
So the tools we use and the Applied Physics were using in the atomic
and molecular physics people worked hard to understand that
and fought with each other about what was believable what was not so we're taking this decades old technique
and applying it to planets. And so we have two problems one is to get good enough data so we can see a robust signal.
And again like back to the image you could have a very blurry image in low light
and you could think you're seeing something
and you wouldn't be able to prove to someone else that you're really seen the scene you think you're seeing.
So we have to have good enough data so everybody can look at the data.
Every Strummer and they'll say yes I do see a spectral feature I do see a signal but the noise. It's not a picture no.
You know I could. Well think of how to explain this to you. I do have a. Yes we do.
Like I wish I could show this to you. Maybe maybe tomorrow. I can show you a picture.
I have a nice printer at my office but what I'm just going to walk you through it now
but what we do is we imagine rain. Imagine for a moment you see a rainbow.
If you could look at that rainbow very closely you would see that some parts of the colors are missing.
You would see literally out of that rainbow color the red orange yellow green blue you would actually see little pieces
that look black black lines as if someone took a marker and just drew a black line.
And that's we do that in astronomy we break up the white light of the sun or stars and we see some lines missing.
But those lines aren't just sharp they may have a gradient at the edges would be a bit fuzzy at the edges
and very dark in the center and believe or not in the old days people would take photographic plates
and they record these you know they have a prism that broke up the light into colors
and they would literally see these dark lines and they put it on a table in China late through it
and then they would measure how much light gets through where these dark lines are
and from that they would make a curve. So now. No light. Let me think this. OK so no lights getting weight.
They'd say no lights getting through than all the sudden a lot of light gets through you know it would be some kind of
curve that is somewhat. And then they'd have another little blip and then another one.
And that's how we met make a measurement of the spectrum.
Not with photographic plates anymore it's all digital and from that yes we have to do interpretation.
But we understand how atoms and molecules absorb radiation both from calculations of quantum mechanics
and also from laboratory measurements and so yes it may seem like a leap of faith.
But we are building our knowledge and tools that have been used for decades for astronomy
and for Earth's Earth's atmosphere observing. We're doing.
Yes in some ways yes we are doing the hard work for future scientists because the signals weren't study now are so weak
and so faint and the techniques we have to use are brand new compared to how we study stars in our own earth this year.
And have to think about that for a minute see.
And by the way that's just a tough question to ask because each of you could. Ask yourself the same thing.
Why are you doing what you're doing know at some level we just don't know I mean we do it because we just love doing it
and it seems exciting and fun and it's it's amazing.
But I have to say for myself even ever since I was a child I always wondered what is out there
when I saw the sky for the first time the dark sky really really dark.
Tons of stars like so many stars I couldn't believe it. No one had I had never even known that that was out there.
Ever since I saw those stars part of me has always wondered what else is there.
But there's another attraction to that's a little more.
You know there's that one thing that sense of wonder
but that's not what happens on a daily basis because we're just you know getting through the day
and getting our tedious work done.
But there's this other really beautiful thing in science
and that is that you can explain the world around you with equations.
And just the fact that we can write down basically starting with some very basic laws of physics
and then some more complicated ones like with quantum mechanics.
And gravity and pressure and we can work through all these basic things these building blocks of physics
and describe an atmosphere far away and get data with the Hubble Space Telescope and actually interpret all that
and make sense from it using basic physics is very satisfying.
I mean we have discovered a lot of things they're a little more academic in a way. It doesn't it's not quite that.
You know that abrupt that you see something so I can try to think about. OK You know I can explain that.
Yeah let's see. Yes the times when we when we like my team or I you know get data and see something that.
Just so shockingly unexpected it's extremely exciting.
It doesn't happen very often and sometimes it happens and it turns out to be nothing when you go back
and take more observations but you know that moment of discovery is just amazing.
It doesn't happen often enough to be the main reason why you know why I'm a scientist. But it's definitely exciting.
I have a different type of excitement though and the reason why I do it is.
I can conceive of an idea of something that just seems truly unheard of an amazing.
And then it can take a year or two or more sometimes to just work through the possibility.
And when you find out that something that this crazy thing you thought of turns out to be right. That's a discovery.
I can maybe work on trying to articulate this but you know there is that sense of discovery of getting data
and seen a signal going Wow I just can't believe we found this I can't believe a planet like this
when I think I found exists. That's definitely an aha moment but there's another more complicated.
A ha moment where we conceive of something and work through a project.
And you find something just totally amazing that you hadn't thought of founding for and that is just so amazing
and actually one of these I'll just tell you a little bit about it because it's my favorite project right now
and you'll meet one of the team members tomorrow at work.
We'll talk and Remy had specifically asked us to talk about this
but it was actually I was working on a project about bio signature gases gases that life might produce
and at that time.
Charles and I we actually just were celebrating our first year of marriage
but at that time we were just kind of getting to know each other and he'd ask me a question
and Charles had asked me well out of all those molecules in our atmosphere in Earth's atmosphere.
How many of those does life produce and it was an amazing question because I looked it up.
I didn't know and I went through tables of what's in Earth's atmosphere
and I found that every gas in our atmosphere to the part petroleum level by volume so if you would capture.
Part per trillion. So if you would to capture like a canister of air.
And measure how much gas is in there
and like you know for every cubic centimeter one part in a trillion is a certain type of gas.
So all gases in our atmosphere just means many of them.
There's about three dozen of them up to that level of abundance. They're all produced by life.
Now most of them have a dominant production from some other source like Jew physics like volcanoes
or photochemistry in the atmosphere but they're also all produced by life and this is amazing
and this is the type of thing that's like Ha.
Is that just some weird coincidence or does it have meaning
and so that I actually worked with the project I was already working on about the range of gases that life on earth
produces it set off a kind of chain of events because I had a theory that I thought partly based on this question about
what's in our atmosphere that life produces all gases.
I thought perhaps life produces every single gas we can ever imagine.
And so I started on a long project I had to convince two of my biochemistry colleagues why I had to convince one of my
main colleagues. He works in biochemistry to do the project and he thought it was silly.
Actually that was the most silliest thing he'd ever heard. He refused to work on it. Hate.
Well then I managed to get another person interested
and I did a kind of scientific matchmaking between these two people
and we all three of us started to work on the project
and ultimately we collected a list of all molecules that are in gas form at temperatures we call them standard
temperature and pressure that's are like room temperature room pressure surface pressure on earth
and we found that it's not true actually.
So in this case despite this excitement that I might have come across this concept that life produces all gases it
turned out to be completely wrong.
Actually it's not so it's only true that life produces about a quarter of those gases a quarter of everything
but we found something even more interesting actually on this journey that in the set of.
Molecules
or molecular fragments that are that exist in general that there are certain pattern amongst the fragments of molecules
that life doesn't produce so life seems to prefer producing producing some types of molecules
and other types of molecular fragments life never produces And so right now we're pursuing that avenue of research to
see what it what it entails and we think it may actually be very helpful in the end for toxicology
and perhaps even from ecology so that actually is so exciting because we sort out with one thing it's like we're
tracking to the South Pole we have a goal we're going to get there.
We have a destination want to go to the South Pole
but instead we discover something else that there's this mountain in Antarctica it's really worth exploring.
And we hike up that mountain then we went in the wrong way. Then we have to go a different way.
And finally we get somewhere that was just so breathtakingly amazing we never conceived of it
and we're in the process of doing that now.
And we're not at the point where we can say that we found something amazing
but I really feel strongly that this is going to be awesome. OK that's a good one.
Sometimes yes sometimes I feel like I'm in a wilderness.
Well in this particular wilderness The funny thing is we have to learn our skills as we go.
It's like we're only outfitted with the most rudimentary gear.
And we have to develop our tools and find out what we need as we go.
Actually it's one of reminds me to a bit of exploring I used to spend a lot more time in the outdoors than I do now.
When I was younger and you go on a trip and not know what you're doing.
We're going to trip and maybe you'd make a mistake and something would go wrong.
Maybe you're just wet all night because you couldn't your tent was leaking or you had some problem
and the next time you know you can go home and think through what you did wrong and go back out there
and do a better job see it for longer. Comfortable. Be more skilled at navigating.
And so we have a chance to go back and learn things I learned Python.
It's now language that everybody knows how to use so when it's Python. OK so you guys don't know how to use it.
It's a computer language. Yeah computer language.
OK because if you said I just learned Python at MIT I'd be like really. You're like a child.
OK So what happened was it's like I'm liking that skill I need a new skill.
Because what we're dealing with is we call it's a big data problem and informatics problem.
And we have to we still just like the explorer in the outdoors.
We can go back and outfit ourselves in a better way and that actually involves just learning a new skill.
So I did learn how to program Python I did like an online class. You can you know with Python and programming.
It's like learning a language like you can learn and try to you can go.
Let's say to somewhere foreign to us like let's say Asia. You could pick up a few words enough to get around.
Or you could decide you're going to learn that language very thoroughly
and do it right from the start so that you have what you need to get through whatever situation you encounter. So yes.
Python computer programming language.
Well was more because we now have fourteen thousand molecules what are we going to do with them
or the fragments of molecules
and we have to now compare those to lists of toxicity molecules that are toxic we have to be able to go to websites
and get information by what we call scraping them and we have to go
and retrieve a lot of data we have to you know mass be able to mass compare things with each other in a way that this
particular language makes it very easy to do.
Oh is there a danger you think oh right in this case what I mean is what in this case what we're trying to do is see
whether the fragments of molecules are building blocks in any way for anything related to lie.
If on earth and well they're not talks at chemicals we're just doing things like in our computer. Oh yeah me something.
Well Or yeah.
Let me mix plane a little better
but in this particular application it's not related exoplanets what we're thinking is that this.
You know our joy Norma's database now that has molecular fragments and molecules that life that we know if life.
We don't know but we've tabulated from the literature that whether life produces it
or not if there's a bunch of molecules or fragments of all kills that life is not producing
and those same molecular fragments show up in toxic chemicals.
You know gives us a clue about new chemicals that may be toxic. Hope that was helpful.
We're just trying to use see what we're just starting to see what this what we think we've got the information we've
gathered on molecules and whether or not.
Life on earth produces them whether it has some other application somewhere in environmental science or
or in drug discovery here on Earth. That's right. Quest.
My main quest is to find another planet like earth and to study planets to see if any of them have signs of life.
With signs. It's a big question in it's a great job.
It's a great quest because science fiction has laid out so many possibilities for us already.
And we like to say science fiction is becoming science fact. At least in terms of our research.
I'm sure it's I'm sure there is life out there somewhere. There.
Are hundreds of billions of stars in our Milky Way galaxy
and we think there are hundreds of billions of planets out there.
So you know why because well the ingredients for life are everywhere we look in astronomy water is very common.
It's an extremely common planetary building block
when we look into interstellar space the disk the almost nothingness between stars we can see astronomers actually
still see complex organic molecules.
You know everywhere we look we see the ingredients for life stars can provide energy most you know there will be
planets that have liquid water on them.
And so it seems inevitable that if life arose here on Earth that it should also be able to arise on another planet
somewhere else in our galaxy.
There's a harder problem though because I am convinced that life is out there somewhere
but the chance of us finding signs of life is a whole other question and that's a very very very challenging journey.
You know it's not so much that that is also definitely a challenge the challenging thing is that planets are so small
and faint it's extremely hard to observe them and we need to look at their atmospheres
and assess all the gases in the atmosphere and find gases that don't belong that are in huge abundance
and that the only way that gas could be in the atmosphere is because of life.
And that's a very hard thing to do because we can we can we found thousands of planets
and that we kind of have under control how to find them.
But how to find enough planets who's who are how to find enough planets that are small like Earth
and how to study their atmospheres in enough detail that is a very hard hard thing to do so.
Right now we can't astronomers are constantly trying to assess.
OK so you would not believe how much how many hours myself and my colleagues
and other people have spent on trying to evaluate how common earth might be.
And we actually don't have an answer right now.
The answer that we work on scientifically it can range anywhere from two percent.
That means like two in one hundred stars like the sun would have an Earth to one hundred percent that all stars like
the sun would have a planet like Earth we really really don't know.
Well there's a space telescope Kepler space telescope that was launched in two thousand and nine
and Kepler stared at one patch of the sky.
For four years and Kepler school was to answer the question How common are other earths that is Earth sized planets
and Earth like orbits about sun like stars and for various reasons Kepler fell short of that goal
but Kepler did tell us that small planets are extremely common small planets that are rocky around stars like the sun
are very very common. So. Absolutely.
I mean we have no doubt that there are small rocky planets out there in great abundance. But the different.
Oh I think I have no doubt there is life out there somewhere.
But the problem we have right now is it's only the very nearest stars.
If they Who's if they have planets that are close enough and bright enough for us to study.
So I've no doubt there is life out there somewhere in our galaxy
or our universe it's almost inevitable just based on sheer numbers
and the fact that building blocks of life are very common
but if the harder question is can we find that any time in the near future because we're limited to studying the very
nearest stars to our own sun.
Be you know you can go and interview a biologist and ask them Do you think there's life out there and they might say.
No No way no evidence.
We don't understand how life on earth forms therefore we can't even speculate why I don't have any clues other than
what I've given you. It's a lot of it's just pure faith admittedly. So. Your life. Absolutely.
We just watched the movie Aliens. I hadn't seen it before actually.
Seen your kids wanted to watch a family movie so were they just gotten old enough so we can all watch movies we all
like you know kids are really little they just wanna watch a cartoon
and scenery Weaver you know we watched the first alien.
And then just the other night I thought it was really scary actually.
There's this old ship that had crashed on a planet as these giant eggs
and everything has been dormant for a very long time.
Meanwhile there's a colony on the planet of people who didn't know about the ship.
Until signori we were told the main character Ripley her spacecraft was found
and she was revived from hibernation sixty years had gone by. And she told him about that.
So they sent apparently had sent the colonists to go investigate the ship
and I was suddenly hear nothing from the calmness on the planet.
So she has to go back and see what's going on
and these are the most scary aliens around you know they are going to kill people
and they they basically capture the humans to act as incubate years for their new life or for their life forms.
So there are there's a ton of them that people want life to be up there with because they weren't scared
and I was then I have to explain it. It's my feel different. Right. Well I will say we're not going to find big sky.
Monsters. So you don't have to worry about that.
How do I know because the tools we have as astronomers right now we're just going to see gases produced by those aliens
gases that they breathe out or you know gases that are produced by the plants that they're eating.
And in fact we won't know what type of life is giving off those gases if it's just slime giant giant fields of bacteria.
Well if they're big monsters like those aliens. I guess they had supposed they are big monsters well.
If they're big monsters giving off gases we still won't know we'll just see the gases that don't belong.
We'll do our best to disentangle that from any volcano volcanic commission
and we'll we'll try to understand if it's if it's created by by life or if it's just what we call false positive.
But how doing. But what will you know that's a different question.
Now because then that question is can we go to the planet can they come here.
And that is still science fiction for now how to get yeah yeah like imagination in science you know it's different from
imagination in creating a film because in that case they can imagine a way the big technological challenges you know
they don't have to explain how Ripley and the other crew can you get on a ship
and hibernate for a while until they get to the new planet and land there and everything like that.
So we definitely do use our imagination but not quite in that same way. Or. You know. One. More. Right.
Or you know maybe. It's a tricky one. We have to think about that for a minute.
Possibly you know we still need to use like our creativity and imagination in solving a problem.
We have a vision of what we think we you know we're trying to get to we have to have that. When you do. What do I see.
Well depending on the day.
I mean I'm not sure actually that question's not an easy one for me to answer because I've not thought of.
Not thought of it that way in a very long time. But I have to think more about it.
Well there are definitely you know I'm not totally sure what you mean in terms of like creativity
or you know envisioning your fantasy of what could happen.
I mean it could come at any level like we have the Starship Project a giant specially shape screen we want to put in
space and that wasn't my idea but the people who had thought of it in the one nine hundred sixty S.
It is kind of a fantasy because it is kind of a fantasy because it's so far fetched like even for that to even be
possible but over the decades we've whittled away at the Technological progress in trying to make that a reality.
But now I feel like I need to be more creative has a fair question.
You know there's definitely a lot of instinct involved. So there's you know in sometimes there's.
You know there's two different types of instinct. One of them is it's like when.
We're imagine we're in the wilderness and I see this river and I know I've got to get down the river.
And there's giant Rapids and I just I think I can do this.
And that's not a fact based intuition it's just a gut feeling
and part of it's a desperation I need to get down that river I'm not going to get to where I'm going
and you kind of take a leap of faith and just go for it.
That's definitely one kind of tool or
or instinct that I've used before I actually have a vision of what I think will happen
but I have no idea how to get from A to B.
and I have to take a leap of faith that I can do it even I don't really have the tools I'm just going to go.
The other intuition. I have experience is one of accumulated. Six.
Yes with that first type of intuition
and then I know I can do it even though I don't still don't have the tools I know that I've been able to find the tools
and that I can still do that one more time again.
So I definitely intuition is a huge part of finding your way through here. I think I think so yeah actually I think.
It's all touchy because you know. OK.
I can't speak for my colleagues at MIT but I'm pretty sure we're all often accused of being arrogant.
So I don't want to come across as too arrogant
but yes I think I'm blessed with a special intuition in that because it's that everybody has it actually
and most people ignore it or it's hidden or they don't use it. It's that gut instinct of this is right.
I feel this is big. I'm going to do this.
I know this is going to be big and I've had that feeling many times and yeah it's not part of this interview
but I love talking about Charles because he and I had a great time we first met.
I had my gut instinct about him like from like almost the second I met him like that's a sort of different thing.
But many more people will you know wonder Sam that.
But yes I have that in science
and I have that about this project that's not is related to finding life elsewhere of all the molecules.
And it's wonderful. Now because I'm able to. Trust my instinct.
More like success actually I think it would be more like an instinct to succeed because I think survival is just like
how do I get enough money to get food. I've got to make sure my children are safe.
I think those things also involve instinct but it's more it's like the next level.
Now that everything's OK and things function and I'm not worried about surviving.
What can I do to just be a Super Chief or and make impact and reach all my dreams. I very well quit now.
And so I'm having a moment of self reflection because now I. I feel like I need to do more.
That's the ambitious part is person's problem you always feel like you need to do more and get more done
and do bigger things I was in a bit of a rest period though in my career. Resting phase now.
So I wasn't thinking in that way sort of taking some time off not time off
but you know not working twenty four seven and going all out. Well my main thing I'm working on.
Well you know you can expect is that in time I'll be able to report to you one way or the other whether
or not we think we have found signs of life on another planet. Or. That wasn't tomorrow.
That's like twenty thirty years from now.
I said I can report one way or the other so I may come back and say around the nearest thirty stars.
I might be able to say we have planets like Earth. We found five of them.
We've studied their atmospheres one has a suggestion that it might have a sign of life
but it's not good enough for us to say anything for sure.
I might come back and report that but at least I would have answered it one way
or the other for the nearest stars that we have this. Right but it is ambitious it's like us saying here is a group.
We've just decided to go to the North Pole. We don't know how we're going to get there. But we think we can do it.
So a lot of things have to work. You know or go over the life. It was alien. Right. Well I'm not. Yes that's right.
It was alien. Yeah. Like. You were right and right.
OK Let me think like well like yes and no because we're not finding the earth like we're going to go there or not us.
Maybe someone in the future will figure that out but we're not going to go and go camping
or we're not going to go there and like you know work through the wilderness and find giant monsters.
It's just you know half of it's in our imagination going to see a point of light.
It just a pale blue dot or a pale bread daughter just some little tiny thing.
And all the interpretation we get we're like We started out talking about were interpreting what we see we can't
guarantee this all we're not going to pictures of of civilizations or the Great Wall of China equivalent
or pyramids we're not going to see any features like that we can see a point of light.
We're going to know it's orbiting a star.
We're going to be able to say something about the mass and size of the planet and what's in the atmosphere.
What kind of air does that planet have and we're going to put a picture together based on scientific tools
and that's how we're going to know if we found another Earth. So it's our modern day version of exploring.
You know we've explored pretty much every landmass parts of the oceans remain unexplored
but we know our planet very well right now.
And space is a vast frontier that's still out there for us waiting to be explored who we were.
Is starting to be possible for sure.
I mean it's the first time ever in human history people have considered sending probes to other star systems.
It's still quite a ways off.
I believe some day humans will find a way to get there but it may be hundreds or thousands of years from now.
I think our desire to explore is just so tremendous. But as humans we want to go we want to explore.
We first have to go to Mars. You know. Me myself no I don't want to. I don't want to go to space.
Actually I know that sounds.
Thing is I don't like small spaces and I don't get along all that well with other people
and I just don't want to be confined to a little tiny spot for the you know for decades.
So space is a space ship of my own maybe you know once. You. You know if you know you know. Well see.
What do I actually do. When I'm working there.
Well I often work on my computer which programming or just other things meet with students
and my research team members we talk about things and try to figure things out. Oh I'm thinking Yeah.
I'm usually working and the best thing is I'm in the zone. You know when you're in the zone in the world goes away.
You know you're doing your best work.
OK Well I think if it happens like when you do your very best work
and you're right where you're supposed to be then everything else goes away.
It's just like you and yourself and your work
and really just what happens is you might get a knock on the door a phone call and you snap out of it you know.
Oh I didn't even realize but I was aware of the world around me I was just involved with what I was thinking.
I mean this and then I'm in the zone. Yes actually.
One time the first time I was in the zone actually that I realized that I was in high school
and I was played in the band.
And I had a piccolo It's like a flute smaller and I actually came across playing the piccolo or the flute but.
I had a flute sometimes gets a special role it's like the singing voice because it's so high
and at the very end of this piece I had to play it was just me and I was kind of obviously nervous and stuff
and one time even missed it entirely. What.
I had to get that and I realized when I said finish that little phrase with the flow.
I was like oh my gosh there's a world here there's Marcus tra. But actually been lost in the sort of perfect.
Non thought process of just being and playing the flute like a harmony like things were just happening
and I wasn't aware of it at all. So if I can get in the zone. I know I'm getting my best work done.
So we're almost center and you know when you enter it of we're just talking and these folks here go away
and I forget about Charles I'm not worried about the kids getting home like his phone just you don't hear about it.
I've looked at his phone it's his one of the kids actually has a job.
He's eleven
but he has like a babysitting job down the street so that lady just wrote him so that I'm not in the zone if I can see
hear that phone and I see.
Alisa wrote to him more times now day and we have a babysitter who's going to be coming soon
and like oh if I'm not think about that stuff and all I can see is you
and the question I'm thinking about the question and I'm not that and then we're in the zone so we can get in the zone.
In fact the best like the best interviews
and like if you're When people if they want to take my photograph it's very hard to do because you can't be like in the
zone with unless you can get in the zone and like really give to the camera.
You can't get the interviews or the pictures just don't come across right.
It's very difficult actually now how do we get in the zone like I need a good night's sleep.
I need to not be worried about other things I've got to put my phone away and not be distracted.
I need to clear out all the things I'm worried about.
The got to answer an e-mail
or get a phone call out of the way so you know if I have a negative confrontation that has to happen at work.
I've got to do all those things. So I can't force myself to be in the zone but I can create the right environment.
So that I can focus. Right. It's because you're such a great interviewer.
I wasn't expecting those I wasn't expecting this level of question so. Just. If you break it you know I understand.
Something about it but I feel like everybody has a new might not know what you're saying to me.
Sometimes you are in a flow. Like I use a White Water paddle.
And if you're in like a hard wrap and you have no choice but to be in the zone.
There's like you have to make these really quick decisions and there's big waves
and you feel like you're part of the river and you're everything's just happening then you finish like so happy
and you made it through in the that thrill and that scared ness is kind of gone.
You just look around like wow OK but that moment you were in the rapids figuring out what to do and go
and it was just pure being like pure living.
You know I think a limp athletes must do it as well I think in their case they're there in the zone you know they're
not thinking about dinner like what they have to do when they get home or.
For a more common problem or argument from somebody else. Or maybe I'm on the wrong people.
Or I think I'm just good at coming along on a lot.
The zone is very special and doesn't happen all the time but I'm very good at compartmentalizing.
Again I have a problem I can just not worry about it for a while. Unless it's a very big problem.
OK so I have thought about this but I haven't really talked about it before anybody.
I do see being a scientist like being in the limbic athlete.
Like I need big periods of rest or literally just do nothing and I love my brain just like it's not watching T.V.
It's not region a scary book. It's just like nothingness.
Because I've got to rest my brain
and I feel like I do know how do you know take care of myself so I can get where I need to be to do great work.
But it's like recharging your batteries. You know doing nothing.
Not really thinking just some quiet time I don't mean meditating or anything.
I'm just thinking like I'm at home really hours are going like what I did this morning just didn't really do anything
but you know what not really necessary.
Think about nothing like I'm cleaning up more minor things that don't require a lot of brainpower.
You know clean up doing some laundry. You know making plans for whatever I have to do later.
So yeah parking research exactly.
Like I liken it to an athlete who you can't be training all the time I mean that would be negative.
That would be negative for doing well actually into rests a little one of my lympics OK now I don't have anything
equivalent to the Olympics because we're not competing you know on a.
Just so the one kilometer race or four hundred meter dash but when I want to be in the zone and do my best work.
I have to be you know. Ready for it.
So I'd say that would be like one of the races the time when I'm really trying to work with a gold medal.
That's probably not the best analogy actually.
But it does take a tremendous amount of energy to to think what sounds funny saying that but if I go to work
and I think really hard all day. I actually come home completely exhausted.
You know I've done no exercise haven't walked upstairs
or haven't you know all day so it seems like people know if you're going all day hike
or you do some major thing physically.
You can just be wiped out at the end of the day and like ready to fall asleep in the instant but thinking actually
when I think very hard problem solve it takes that huge amount of energy in what way.
Might give me here headache or just I can't solve the problem or them so well and then I don't have that
when I'm thinking about work but sometimes I have it. In other situations actually I've seen my friends have it too.
I was just at a conference and four of us who were friends were all at the same conference we started talking
and one of them had that moment where she thought she was going crazy but two of us were talking rapidly
and we kept switching topics. Because we had been in an email chain about a project we're doing.
And she had thought she was just losing it.
But when we explained that we had two different conversations going on and we were jumping back
and forth she felt relief. Sometimes Overthinking gets you in trouble that way because.
You think you might of gotten very confused about something but you find out that it's it's not you was the situation.
When. OK Let me think about that one.
So there are a lot of chases like that there are a lot of cases like that where you go down a path.
Imagine it's like exploring in the wilderness and you just can't get through and you have to back off.
And you park it in a way I'm thinking I want to go there again future
and I do have one particular problem I can't figure out actually unfortunately we couldn't even
when I asked my best student for the past great with physics the two of us even couldn't solve this problem
and the reason is because. I can. Well we're.
We're trying to describe a situation in which the limits of planet can be stable a split can be unstable
and just evaporate if it doesn't have enough gravity it can't hold onto its material
but the equations we're using only describe a planet that is bound together so we don't even have the tools
and this is a good example we have no tools and we don't know how to handle this problem.
So I decided to leave that problem.
I didn't get mad and I kind of got a little mad I'll only get really mad if someone else figures it out
and publishes it. But for now instead of me because I know it's a great idea but I'm not one hundred percent.
It's a great idea. So I'm waiting for more data to accumulate so I can know whether or not this idea is good. Or.
Often very often. Or. Often there's. Let me think for a second.
Sometimes it's a practical reason I don't have time or resources or people to carry out that particular problem.
Other times it's just not a priority one can have so many ideas and just not nearly enough time to pursue them
and other times it's just too hard.
The kind of tools that we'd have to develop to work on it
or just figuring out the right physics we need to solve the problem is just beyond what I can do.
Sometimes it gets parked forever. Sometimes it's part two.
I meet the person with the right skills like my biochemistry colleagues who I can work with.
Other times it's just part until the summer.
Until I have time that I'm not teaching or dealing with university tasks to have some time to think through it.
But I can also imagine that you story from what you an idea.
Like this is promising me also if I just have some time or some team to help me it was right.
Sometimes it's definitely frustrating. But part of life is choosing what's important.
What's not and so you know sometimes you just have to choose the one that's important. Go with it.
It's also harder now than it used to be I think when you're younger with less responsibility.
You can just drop everything and focus on that problem you think is so important and really make traction
and finish it.
And now there's just so much going on in just my job
and home that it's harder to just drop things to just focus on one thing.
Where you saw it with this you know while you're alone with your own mind.
And you're thinking of you do you try to see equations or you know what is what is the. Reality.
Well I've never tried to articulate it before.
OK sometimes there's a flash of not colors or light or anything that there's a flash of thinking like a conclusion.
It's reached in advance of getting their groove reach and yes it's kind of like I'll be working away at something
and then I'll kind of get that almost like the only way I can describe it in the best case is.
Like I realize what the answer is before I get there. And find out. I have to find out how to get there.
Sometimes it's a negative. Where in the cell and I'm working I just realize it's not going to work.
But I still want to do my due diligence to make sure that this idea is not going to pan out to be sure that it's NOT
have to be sure that's not right or right even in that case but if you when you close your eyes
when you're in the zone when you see I don't know if I can answer that. Actually I don't know. So somehow I think.
Scientists and artists and let's say. Way of thinking I think so.
Well what's the way the artists think in the sound is so true and if you do any kind of work and make a baby.
He's got from what I write goes yes yes yes with reality.
You only difference is the artist for what I do but also to live life you have I think you're going to. I think so.
Because you're always certain you will never get to see it and know who's always bigger
or the thing is I feel like I am one person out of a long chain of people in all directions.
And so I feel I'll be satisfied if I can accomplish. You know my goal or my life's work.
As long as the next person in front of me is ready to go.
So I may never reach what truth is or what I say even what I set out in the biggest sense of the word
but as long as I know it will be carried on or someone else will keep the search going I'm OK with it. Yeah.
You know maybe go back to. Oh please let me. You know we don't fall.
The data that my team works with come from the Hubble Space Telescope. And the Spitzer Space Telescope.
Well the ultimate form we want to convert the data into look like points on a graph as a function of wavelength.
So we've visible wavelengths where I can see an infrared wavelengths where he cameras can see
and each point has an arab are associated with it and uncertainty of the measurement. And so we just kind of have data.
That as a function of wavelength
and we look for patterns in the data another set of data we use is a time series of data.
And these data come from the Kepler space telescope.
And their data point taken every few seconds but it's been to thirty minutes
and it's on a time sequence so we have one point of a star how bright it is as a function of time.
So these are mostly in minutes minutes or minutes but each point will be every minute
or every thirty minutes depending on which mode that particular target star was observed in.
This point where you are right because these star shaped stars the stars. You know.
OK the baffle me you know we call that a baffle. Because what is this test right.
So OK Well first of all just to back up a little there's many different telescopes
and projects that are ongoing different groups of people all around the world have different projects they're trying to
move forward. The ones I'm involved with. One of them is called Test transiting exoplanet Survey Satellite.
And test is the NASA mission.
It costs two hundred million dollars overall
but for space you have to imagine everything costs one hundred times more than on the ground.
Tests is a space is this test is a satellite the orbiter.
It has a very elliptical orbit so it can spend most of its time away from Earth's the heat and light from Earth.
It was zoom around while it downlinks data and it will spend thirteen point six days away from Earth in a few hours.
You mean by. It will spend each of two orbits on one patch of the sky.
And in two years tests will survey the whole sky looking at stars measuring their brightness as a function of time
searching for planets that transit their host stars they go in front of the star.
And they block out a tiny amount of starlight while they're transitting. And the goal for test actually.
Is to uncover a pool of planets of rocky planets transiting small stars stars much smaller than the sun.
And those stars
and their planets are the first ones that will be able to search for signs of life in the atmosphere using the James
Webb Space Telescope which is the next Hubble Space Telescope if you will.
So we have actually we're working on our very practical plans to find the planets around stars that are close enough to
earth.
So they're bright enough and will look for signs of life in their atmosphere using the James Webb Space Telescope.
So this. OK so the star she does something totally different.
So we'll talk that's way next generation after tests all test itself is actually you know Tessa's it is just for
essentially specialized telephoto lenses. They don't focus they're just fixed.
They have about seven different lenses inside.
They're made almost to be perfectly for no vignetting they're a thermal So they're not going to heat up
or cool down in weird ways and there's four of them attached to a single platform.
And those telescopes believe it or not those cameras they cover a strip of sky ninety degrees by twenty four degrees.
So it's like if you look at the night sky it's like from your horizon all the way to the pole almost that whole strip.
And it's going to twelve of those all across. Sky.
And what Tess is looking for is just measuring star brightness as a function of time every few minutes
or so it'll have a data point. And what Tess is looking for is a special configuration of planetary orbit.
We call it a transit. It's when if we have a star the planet goes in front of the star as seen from the telescope.
And while the star is just a point of light it will drop in brightness by a tiny tiny amount one percent
or a fraction of a percent when the planet goes in front of the star.
And that's what we're looking for this is been pioneered already by the Kepler Space Telescope which found.
Which found thousands of planets transit the star.
And Tess is repeating that experiment but with stars that are much closer to Earth than the coupler stars are.
Well you know the star she comes in is right now I want you to know about these transiting planets are very important.
They're really the main thing we're doing an exoplanet because they're easy to find
but they have to be specially lined up.
Planets orbit since the stellar spin axes it's all random stars are born out of they can collapse this way
or they can collapse this way so transiting planets are very special
and they're also quite rare our own Earth for example is so far from our star.
That if we're looking for an Earth Sun twin only one in two hundred would transit.
An analogy for you is like throwing darts at a dartboard if you're really close to that dart board you can easily get
to the center of the dart board but the further away you go the harder it is because you're angle smaller.
So for Earth and Sun It's actually quite rare that they'll transit and so if we want to find an Earth twin.
If we want to go beyond transiting planets.
We actually eventually have to use a totally different technique than Kepler and tests
and things that are going on now we have to be able to block out the star light so we can see the planet directly.
So in exoplanets it's complicated. We have many different ways to find planets at least six different way.
Maybe seven maybe thirty if you read like pedia.
But it's so many different ways and they're all for a different goal transits are something we can do right now today.
That they rely on a very special configuration
and just to be a little more technical for transmitting planet the drop in brightness is related to the area of the
planet compared to the area of the star. Because that's how much light we're blocking out imagine like a big circle.
That's the star not little circle little disk that's the planet our own Earth actually blocks out about one part in ten
thousand the light of our sun if there's an alien civilization looking back at us
and they have a Kepler space telescope.
They need to measure a star to precision so they can see a drop in brightness of one part in ten thousand
and it's pretty small. Well where we are detectable because our Kepler space telescope can detect. Who the aliens.
Oh they might they might actually because Kepler was the easiest telescope for us to build actually.
So I'm just setting the stage for you to see just how hard planet find is one part in ten thousand I mean do you have
ever have to measure anything to one part in ten thousand like when you're building a renovation
or you know even our project you're not measuring things to four decimal places. It's just not happening.
Now if we want to forget about transiting plants for a moment cause they're rare
and we may run out of them if we're looking for an earth around a nearby sun.
Now we have an even harder problem because our Earth
and reflected light invisible wavelengths that were our ice can see were stars are bright Earth is ten billion times
fainter than the Sun so it's no longer one part in ten thousand we're worried about it's one part in ten billion
and the reason is it's not just the area
but light drops off you know if you're shining a flask flashlight outside of the beam is spreading out the light is
dropping off actually it's weakening with distance and so the sunlight has to travel that distance to hit the earth
and that sunlight is weakening and so with that reflected light.
From the Sun from an Earth sized planets a very very small.
So imagine we're looking for a planet like Earth and it's faint enough itself.
But that fitness is not that our problem in astronomy it's the fact that the Earth out there.
We're looking for is right next to a very bright star the stars ten billion times brighter so we have to suppress the
star light or block out the star light to one part in ten billion.
So the star shade if you will like our next step after we finish with translating planets we're going to do what we
call direct imaging we're going to block out the star light so we can see the planets directly
and we already do this from ground based telescopes.
Only we're reaching one part in one hundred thousand not one part in ten billion.
So we have many more decimal places still difficult.
So the star shape is going to go to space
and it's going to have to formation fly tens of thousands of kilometers away from the telescope in the star shape is a
very specially shape screen that's tens of meters across and this whole thing will line up
and block out the star light so that only the planet light is entering the telescope
and the star she will move across the sky and realign with a new target star over and over again.
It's going to be exciting. It's going to work if the star shade was not my idea but yes.
Recently I led the team that was running the Starship project for about two years.
And we actually brought star shade from being a crazy concept like someone's vision or dream
or fantasy into mainstream astronomy
and we were able to pull together all the groups who've been working on Star shade making technology work here testing
starship in the desert there
and we kind of brought everything up to a level now where it's surprising just in a couple of years.
Astronomers no longer say Star shade. That's dead.
It's never going to work there like of course we want to try to do star shade.
And this actually project I led was a study.
That a NASA sponsored study we can get into more details if you want but that's how I was involved with Star shade.
Yes because you know what's really cool is I have one of the petals of the star shade prototype.
It's five and a half meters. Well because the whole star shade depending on what version you.
We will get funded in the future could be thirty meters across
and each petal is between is will these particular ones are five
and a half meters I can show you some videos later too that will help explain it.
Yes I have the starship petal and I have another artifact.
I'm not sure if it'll get back on time because I was in Washington on the weekend in the.
Level one percent scale version. It's about one meter in diameter. It's a star shaped one percent for size.
It doesn't move this particular one was used in the desert.
It's just like a piece of metal cutout it was used in desert testing where Northrop Grumman Corporation sent a team
repeatedly out to the desert in the Vada.
And they're trying to make sure that the math works that the stars in the very special shape really does block light
the way we expect and they'd have a camera and L.E.D.
Fake star and planet in the star shape blocking out the light of the star so they can see the planets directly.
I can send you some photographs on this as well. So you have the whole story together. Of course. But. OK.
Like literally when I dream or you mean figurative Lee When I dream about the future.
A Literally the funny thing was literally I just I dreamed I was at a conference and just wanted to go home.
So that's kind of my usual life story. I'm on a trip somewhere and I just really don't want to be there.
One of the problems. Yes So my dreams are really not that.
I know I do I tend to dream that I know that's right I have a very realistic dreams just about my everyday life like
when I'm sleeping I'm not dreaming about you know some great adventure of meeting the only instance of like in this
movie Aliens. RIPLEY the main character constantly is dreaming that she was harboring one of these aliens.
You know because they use human bodies is host and speaking out. So I don't really dream.
Literally dreaming like when I'm sleeping that I'm finding a planet or anything.
And fortunately no my dreams are quite tedious and. Usually that.
OK Why do I have more a more pragmatic person actually so I have to I can probably I wouldn't I actually need some time
to think about your questions. They're so good but if you think I do have a dream though. OK I'll take my time.
Well in my dreams planets are everywhere they really are and they're just waiting for us to find them.
And I literally dream of the data we're going to be getting.
And I know it's not going to be spectacular data it's going to be you know our first try.
And I literally dream of the data coming down and finding what we're looking for.
And I believe in my dream so strongly. You know that will be finding oxygen and other gases that don't belong.
But my dream goes a lot further because at some level I I do you know I may not accomplish everything I want in my
lifetime and so my dream extends to my students some of them who are really like my own children.
And I I want them to carry the dream on actually.
And so I do dream of an amazing future whale well beyond what I'm going to accomplish in my life where we have
incredible things happening in space. We have self.
We have self-assembly
or space telescopes we can make telescopes that are bigger than anything we imagined fabrication in space.
We're building giant telescopes and I imagine the future of having just such great data.
That the generation just beyond me.
Can have unequivocal wonderful beautiful data that the signals are so strong
and there's no question that they're seeing spectral features
and that they can sort through all the different possibilities and make a robust claim of life.
On another world and in my dream saw a life then I'm just a hundred years old.
With my husband Charles you know traveling around to conferences
and getting to enjoy the success of the seeds that I planted and I wish my student Mary was around she's actually.
She actually was in the Netherlands actually a low for this big radio telescope you have there.
It's spread out all across the country. Now she's in Belgium but she's one of my people actually my protege's.
I mean she'll probably know unfortunately she's in Europe right now
but I'm just saying that she would like there are some of my students I do really.
I'm really attached to actually when trained.
I mean obviously they're not going to do just what I want them to do in their life just like real children you know.
Don't go and do what you have a plan for them they usually don't do that plan
but I do see a great future exactly like I didn't do it. My father wanted me to yeah. So.
For your you know the thing is like academic life is quite tough actually I mean you're going to see me so successful
and it looks like a great life and I have time and I can do whatever I want
and I have a lot of respect I can I can do whatever I want really and people won't cross me
but it's hard to get there and so I'm not sure if I wish that life for my children of just kind of struggling
and low pay for a while and really you know I want them to find something that they love doing that they're good at.
Because I think that's what needs to be successful.
I think as a parent to it's a little more practical
and I hadn't realised this about why my dad had the reaction he did when I told him I wanted to be an astronomer.
This is a parent you want your children to be self-sufficient. You know you want them to get out there.
So you don't have to support them. Later in their life you know in the moving back home.
You want to be out there and launched we call it and just doing their own thing.
So I have a vision for my children where I want them to be to find a job that works for them
and a lifestyle that they want and I recognize that might not be the same thing that I want for myself
but of course all that said I do secretly hope that one of them does carry on my dream.
Like the I'm going to look into I love the story of the parent and child like growing up and working together
but I feel like they need to carve their own path.
What planets around because they have so much mass there gravity wants to pull them in to us here. So. OK.
Exoplanets scientifically get named after their parent star. So for example we have a star called Upsilon Andromeda.
And when planets were found. They're named Upsilon Andromeda B C D Not too exciting.
And to confuse the matter planets are named in order of their distance from the star
but their order named in order of discovery. So might have Planet be out here and then C. and Then D.
That makes it very confusing.
We have other stars where the stars themselves never had names until a planet was discovered.
Such as Kepler one eighty six.
That would have been Kepler is one hundred eighty sixth Star with the planet found around it.
and those planets would be called Kepler one eighty six B. C. D. E. F. But I'm going to finish the naming question.
Because for a long time we wanted to just name the stars name the planets ourselves
but astronomers don't have the right to do that even if I discover a planet.
I can't name after my child or pet or anything. It's actually not allowed.
And at one point astronomers started to name them
and other people other Strummer's got angry Well you didn't discover that I work on that planet just as much as you do.
Why do you get the right to name it.
So people get all upset about it but recently I'm pleased to tell you that the International Astronomical Union.
The international body that's responsible for naming astronomical objects opened up a competition to the public
and they let different groups first register so individuals weren't allowed but you could be like an astronomy club
or a school group and not and suggest names and then people are allowed to vote on which names they liked
and so eventually a bunch of the planets were named the stars and planets were given names.
Like I wasn't actually no no in fact we were not thinking of them to be honest.
To remember the name of five thousand different planets is way too hard and so in the scientific sense..
We actually like our original naming system. Because if the star is named H D one eight nine seven three three B.
That's the planet name. We know that it's a sun like star because H.D.
Is after a catalog by man named Henry Henry Draper who went out and catalogued all the bright sun like stars.
If it's glees five it when see. Please was another person who named all the red dwarf stars.
Then we know it's a red dwarf star if it's Kepler one eight six F.
We know it's from the Kepler survey so the names as arcane as they may sound they actually work for us.
More like a code the code is more useful than an actual. Actually it's certainly possible.
This happens has not happened to me yet but it has definitely happened in kind.
I'd like to be an example of what happened next. The planets.
One thing that we don't understand how planets form because we all expected going out there searching for planets that
we would simply find solar system copies a star Mercury Venus Earth Mars bigger planets Jupiter Saturn Uranus Neptune.
And wow.
Astronomers found Jupiter's we're on earth should be where Jupiter orbiting it starts closer to its sun we found
Jupiter's ten times closer to their star the mercury is to our sun we found what we call hot super Earths planets.
So close to the star the surface should be hot enough to melt rock
and we see planets with one day period orbits their year is only one a day so we found so many planets is just crazy.
Now people worked on planet formation.
First of all they never predicted this huge range of planetary systems and the funny thing is that.
That off these planet from ation theorists would say.
We predict there will be no planets between one to four masses at orbiting at some distance to their star
and they consciously made predictions like that as soon as our telescopes our instruments could reach smaller planets
their predictions were just completely wrong.
So actually has happened over and over again at least in that field where people predict things
and they end up being completely wrong. So when I give you an example.
It's the obviously easier to blame other people than it is to think of your own work but it always it is possible. OK.
It's certainly possible that you think of something and you have a plan you imagine something and you work it out
and you're sure you're going to find it and you don't find it can happen.